good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I'm
in my garden which can only mean one
thing it's time to harvest the peas do
you rate a bunch of my food a couple
weeks ago so my dad made a fence thanks
dad
now I've already gotten to enjoy quite a
bit of kale and collard greens this year
but it's the first pea harvest and I'm
just so excited I can't wait anymore
heck let's do it let's harvest the peas
and done I got the peas
okay Hank it's time to count up our peas
we've got oh god don't go away no you're
one of my only Peas
okay we've got three peas plus the run
away oh yeah oh yeah that's for peace
we've got there's the fourth P gob will
run away peas well I do the good peas
always run away run away we're at P come
on man oh come on you're ten percent of
my pea crop for the year nine peas it
hasn't been the best pea weather here in
Indianapolis because it went from cold
to hot more of us immediately but we're
not letting that discourage us I think
one way of looking at these nine pieces
that they were very expensive like if
you count all the water and the compost
and the seeds it's about 25 cents of pea
but another way of looking at it is that
my peas are very valuable
walk with me Hank today I'm gonna teach
you how to create the most luxurious and
delicious 9 P snack in the history of
the world let's get to it so if you're
making a luxury 9 P dish the first thing
you're gonna want to do is massage your
peas very gently there are a lot of ways
to do this but my favorite way is to try
to see how many Peas I can fit in a pea
mustache oh no one stuck it's a disaster
usually the next thing I like to do is
just give my peas a basic overview of
some of the factors that affect their
lives because you don't want to eat
uneducated peas and the team playing in
Milton Keynes actually got relegated out
of the third tier if you can believe
that so AFC Wimbledon don't even have to
play them so once you've got your peas
educated and massaged it's time to start
thinking about cooking them and
obviously this is gonna be uncomfortable
mostly for the peas
I recommend gently but firmly explaining
the situation to your peas so listen
guys we've had a good run together but I
am going to eat you now my body is going
to turn you into energy that I will then
use to probably watch TV and then once
you've given your peas what I call the
talk it's time to cook them let's go to
the kitchen so one thing a lot of people
don't know is that unlike asparagus or
kale peas are actually quite
starchie which means you have to boil
them for a little longer an undercooked
pea is just not that good
great now I got eight Peas I like to
boil my water in a tiny artisanal pot
because you know I've already wasted
enough water growing the eight Peas
there we go
you know what they say about a watched
pot it will eventually boil you're gonna
drop in your 8 remaining peas I'd say
for about like five minutes sometimes it
helps the peas cook if you sing them a
little song did you ever know that
you're my hero I'm really sorry about
that pun it sucked
while you're waiting I recommend looking
at art like this picture when I first
got it I thought it was about Hollywood
coming for YouTube and then later I
thought it was about YouTube coming for
Hollywood and now I don't know what I
think then you use your pee scooper to
scoop out it dang it then plate your 8
cooked peas in a soy sauce container and
then at last it's time to eat your 8
Peas I recommend eating them one at a
time mmm mmm tastes a lot like the piece
you get at the grocery store so Hank if
you want to have a luxury pee experience
nope that doesn't sound right no no at
any rate I cannot recommend gardening
enough really Hank I'll see you on
Friday